German Chancellor Angela Merkel has
announced a further easing of lockdown
restrictions but warns that they could
be re-imposed if the rate of coronavirus
infection increases again places of
worship children's playgrounds and
museums are being allowed to reopen but
large gatherings including major
sporting events remained banned until at
least the end of August Chancellor
Angela Merkel defended a step-by-step
approach as she outlined details of the
latest easing of restrictions in Germany
following a virtual meeting with the 16
state premiers it's been the fifth
annual fall I am firmly convinced that
the interests of the economy and also
the interests of social contacts are
best pursued if we consider that we can
take steps forward in allowing more
contacts but only if we don't have to
take steps back and that's why we have
to stay careful and a dear to hygiene
measures you know more normal under the
new rules religious gatherings are
allowed again provided hygiene and
distancing requirements are met in
churches synagogues and mosques visits
to zoos museums and memorials will also
be possible again under the same
requirements intensive care units and
hospitals will start receiving non
covert 19 patients again and playgrounds
can reopen as early as this week but two
decisions were postponed for now
one should Germany's Bundesliga soccer
league resumed its season with games
behind closed doors and two just which
requirements need to be met before
schools and childcare facilities can
reopen gradually Angela Merkel said it
was important to get a clearer idea of
the impact of the first steps to ease
the lockdown two weeks ago before
deciding on the next steps and that will
happen next Wednesday let's get more now
from DW political correspondent Hans
Plante good to see you Hans what do
these latest announcements from the
German government tell us I think the
main message is the one Daniel
Immaculate is deciding to the other side
of caution she is saying again and again
that it would be counterproductive to go
ahead quickly with lifting
various aspects of the locker but it is
necessary to measure the text of the
first of step or two
the gentleman is doing this in two-week
periods to doing a manager lifting of
some rhythms and it's waiting for about
two weeks to see what ik those liftings
will have amber of effect infections in
the country and if effect is
controllable then this step will be
implemented so she's being instead of
opening a huge it is ortant to measure
what the various measures have and only
if the infection rate does increase only
then can new steps be taken in that
sense the lifting were announced
yesterday were in fact out of schedule
as were they were not in those two
two-week periods but the efforts decided
that indeed areas such as memes and
small religious gatherings and so on
these would not have a huge effect on
the infection rate in in Germany so
these liftings were a kind of sense of
hope in a sense out of schedule hans
give us a sense of the balancing act
that the Chancellor and the regional
leaders are having to perform here
mostly there is huge a huge amount of
pressure on politicians on the
government on the various regional
leaders firstly from business and there
are tens of thousands of businesses that
are facing ruin basically there are
millions of people that are not earning
any money or on some sort of short pay
so the pressure on the business side
that pressure for people back to work is
enormous at the same time there is an
increasing restless than the German
population after several weeks of being
basically restricted to their homes
especially families with children I
think are running out of patience with
their children one could say so the
fresh water for some sort of social
relaxation for some sort of normal life
to be reestablished
is all sorry very big angular magma has
to balance that obvious against
health of the population and the
capacity of the German system to deal
with the infections of the corona virus
so with that balance Angela Merkel as I
said is earning on the support and being
very careful about what steps to take
from one week next Huns thank you so
much
DW political correspondent Hans blunt
there well in the u.s. too more than two
dozen states are moving ahead with plans
to relax coronavirus restrictions and
reopen their economies federal social
distancing guidelines to curb spread of
the virus expire at midnight local time
on Thursday and are not being extended
speaking at the White House President
Trump again spoke of the need to restart
the economy despite warnings from
infectious disease experts of a possible
resurgence of the outbreak nobody has
spent more time late in the evening
thinking about what's happened to this
country in a short period of time but at
the same time we have to get our country
open again and we're doing that step by
step Tennessee is an example step by
step we're opening up our country
well DW Washington correspondent Oliver
salad has this update for us now as many
states prepare to get back to business
president Trump's economic reopening
guidance expired on Thursday and that
now puts the burden on the states the
governors will have the final say about
when and how to reopen the economy and
in fact more than half of the states is
trying to go back to normal to loosen
the restrictions gradually step by step
which will be a hard and difficult pass
for them and an experienced citizens
will have to get used to security
requirements will be high a visit to the
barber shop will include masks and
gloves but one thing is clear though no
matter how hard the states try experts
and advisors issued stark warnings
opening the economy at this point in
time can lead to a backlash and in some
states the curve has not even flattened
plus there's not enough testing
available but at the same time the
pressure on President Trump is in
normos thirty million Americans have
filed for unemployment in recent weeks
and the u.s. went from a booming economy
to a crash the country hasn't seen in
decades and the election is getting
closer Americans are taking to the polls
in six months from now in the US state
of Michigan hundreds of demonstrators
crowded inside the Capitol building on
Thursday to protest the government's the
governor's coronavirus lockdown order
some demonstrators carried rifles and
attempted to enter the legislative
chamber but were held back by police for
the second time in two weeks protesters
gathered outside the State Capitol in
Michigan to demand an end to stay at
home orders and business restrictions
but this time they didn't stop there
hundreds of demonstrators stormed the
Capitol building to condemn a plan by
the Democratic state governor to extend
emergency powers for another month some
of them were armed with rifles I signed
an executive order this morning governor
Gretchen Whitmer has already issued an
executive order to extend a state of
emergency and protesters say that's a
violation of their rights
the virus is here it's going to be here
so we need to get out and live our lives
and quit taking our economy deep into
socialism
it's time to let people go back to work
that's all there is to it
the measures imposed to contain the
pandemic have inflicted unprecedented
economic pain and uncertainty they're
free to stay in their homes that's what
freedom is this isn't freedom already
more than 30 million Americans have
filed for unemployment benefits
something not seen since the Great
Depression to prevent further economic
decline some states are preparing to
loosen coronavirus restrictions and
restart their economies in Georgia the
shelter and place rules ended at
midnight for all but the elderly and
fragile as global concerns grow about
the spread of the corona virus eight
agencies and governments are warning
about the vulnerability of refugees in
Kenya the government has banned entry to
two refugee camps housing 400,000 people
DWS Idris Mukhtar reports now from Kenya
in a place miles away from home
this group of vulnerable refugees is
facing an unknown enemy it's a fear that
keeps this model for up at night sido
Mohammad already survived war violence
and drought in neighboring Somalia
before arriving in this crowded refugee
camp more than 25 years ago there is a
lot of fear we can't sleep and movement
is restricted there's not much work we
pray to God that there will be no Corona
cases here because if the virus reaches
us I don't think a lot of people will
survive a concern echoed by UNHCR the UN
refugee agency which has called for
emergency funding to help displaced
people though they've been no confirmed
cases of the virus here yet the existing
conditions would fail it spread we all
live very close to each other up to 30
people live in one camp section this
includes children believe people with
diabetes
high blood pressure that could become a
big problem a tragedy
many of the refugees seem more concerned
about their livelihoods than the virus
itself many businesses have also been
affected it's really hard for us to make
ends meet
well from what I've heard unlike most
people here I follow the news and social
media very closely by washing your hands
covering your face with a mask and if
you're seeing a doctor or someone who
can take care of you for now see IDO is
very much a believer that the virus can
be stopped if everyone plays their part
off more on the situation in one of the
biggest refugee camps in the world I
spoke to a short time ago - Philip a
cross on Taylor she's Country Director
at Kerr international in Kenya I asked
her what she thinks will happen if the
corona virus reaches that sealed off
Dadda
Kemp if the coronaviruses reaches that
camp as in many parts of Kenya is deeply
unprepared I mean we have I mean the
UNHCR has been working with the
government but still we have facilities
for 2,000 in quarantine we've got a
hundred and ten beds in in an isolation
unit that's it
and there's 270,000 people up there of
which you know two hundred and forty
eight hundred and thirty of German for
32 and 48 are refugees it's really
really worrying scenario what in your
opinion needs to be done to avert a
medical disaster in camps like dub I
think we're doing what we can and we're
spending a lot more money on soap we're
running our water 12 hours and 12 hours
a day on on a slightly old interest
concerns is a bit to make sure that
people are having enough access to
washing their hands making sure their
houses are clean and pulling all the
hygiene protocols we're making sure that
all the distancing things when we're
distributing food out is happening
that's what has to be done let me ask
you does Kenya have sufficient resources
to deal with this pandemic whether we're
talking about the camp or just the
country in general no I think I think
that's pretty well agreed across the
continent and many countries in Africa
would you'll be
but that's why there's been spending so
much time and effort trying to prevent
the spread we do not have the resources
to cope with her if we get the sort of
cases and the case numbers we're bidding
in Europe and America it's just not
possible we don't have the isolation
beds we don't have the medical equipment
there is just not here you been
Secretary General Antonio Guterres says
that the international community is not
delivering on its commitments to help
Africa and other developing countries
facing this pandemic what do you think
the international community should be
doing we need more money for PPE for
protection equipment we need we need
more money to do hygiene messaging I
mean there's very little money coming in
to do any of the work that's that's
helping to prevent all of these things
we're doing our best doing messaging
over the radios the government's doing
the job trying to make sure that it's
all contained but it's not enough and
it's too little there's not enough free
Mars there's not enough free safe
there's not enough free water and we
have a very large population of people
that very little not just the refugees
miss Kraus time to make more out weave
that's that's a very clear message miss
Kraus on and Taylor thank you so much
for talking with us that was Philip
across on Taylor she's country director
at Kerr international in Kenya and
joined us from Nairobi thank you very
much
now for a brief look at some of the
other stories making headlines around
the world today uN chief Antonio
Guterres has criticized the lack of
international cooperation in the corona
virus crisis guitarist's said a UN
appeal for two billion dollars to them
for the most vulnerable including
refugees and internally displaced people
has only been half funded US
intelligence agencies say they agree
with the scientific consensus that it's
unlikely the corona virus was
bioengineered the statement comes as
President Trump again touts the theory
that the virus leaked from a lab in
China the World Health Organization has
warned that the outbreak is still
picking up speed across Africa despite
efforts to contain it
Malaysia will allow the majority of
businesses to reopen next week as the
pace of new cases has slowed in recent
days and a million people are now known
to have recovered from corona virus
infections worldwide though it's unclear
how many of them have permanent health
damage due to the virus